hi I'm Leslie curry from the Yale School
of Public Health welcome back to our
series on qualitative research methods
this module is on developing a
qualitative research question to remind
us an overview of the modules our goal
in this series is to enhance our
capacity to conceptualize design and
conduct qualitative research in the
Health Sciences there are six modules in
the series the first is what is
qualitative research the second
developing a qualitative research
question the third and fourth address
major qualitative study designs
interviews and focus groups the fifth
presents an overview of qualitative data
analysis and the last module addresses
the issue of scientific rigor and
qualitative research this module in this
module we'll explore developing a
qualitative research question
well-formed questions are key to good
research for a number of reasons first a
well-formed research question defines
the purpose of the research this is very
important to set boundaries around the
edges of our research question to
identify the gap in the literature that
we're trying to address well-formed
research questions can help us determine
the appropriate methods in order to
answer that question we don't want to
begin with I have students who come to
me and say I want to do a study using
focus groups or I'd like to do a study
using interviews with patients and
family members well we don't start with
a methodology rather we start with a
research question the knowledge gap that
we're trying to fill and work then in
that direction to determining the
methodology that suits that question a
well-formed research question can also
guide our study planning so if we're
very precise in scripting our research
question this will help us in guiding
efforts to allocate resources and time
in order to implement the study and
provide enough time for
analysis and reporting and lastly a
well-formed research question is
critical it's important in quantitative
methods as well but critical in
qualitative methods for helping frame
the analysis and the findings as we'll
see in the modules on in-depth
interviews and focus groups these
approaches generate voluminous amounts
of data often hundreds of pages of
narrative transcripts and many potential
directions could be followed in the
analysis a well scoped research question
will remind us what is the primary focus
of this question and will help us focus
ourselves in both the analytic process
and in the dissemination the writing of
the findings so there are a number of
topics that are well suited for
qualitative research
let's review together just just a few
examples the first is the role of
organizational context in implementing a
new technology or practice so for
example you might imagine elan
electronic medical records and a new
software for EMR being implemented in a
primary care clinic setting what is the
role of the organizational the broader
environment in the implementing of that
technology what are the barriers and
facilitators in that specific
environment a second broad area of
topics are complex social processes you
might imagine the dynamics between
formal and informal caregivers and
caring for a frail homebound older adult
living in the community what are those
dynamics like the third patient
perceptions of healthcare access and
quality in this instance we might be
interested in the patient experience of
informed consent discussions with a
physician and lastly the beliefs and
motive motivations underlying health
behaviors is a potential focal area for
qualitative research for example what is
an individual's preference around
preventive screening procedures for
breast cancer
colon cancer so these are just some give
you a sense of some topics that are well
suited for a qualitative methodology but
of course there there are a whole range
of possibilities so let's move to
conceptualizing a qualitative research
question what does it mean to to develop
a question that's going to give us those
benefits that we reviewed earlier first
a qualitative research question must be
inductive and exploratory we don't come
to the question with any assumptions or
hypotheses about what is going on rather
very open exploration of the phenomenon
of interest a qualitative research
question is framed as a research
question an aim or objective again there
are no hypotheses that we're setting out
to test per se conceptualizing a
research question in qualitative
traditions really requires very careful
attention to focusing on a single
phenomenon concept or idea again because
the risk the risk is that there will be
much generated and by way of the data
that may be relevant to our topic but
also perhaps tanzen tangential so the
focus is really very critical for
feasibility and for answering that
particular gap with precision so let's
look at writing a research question we
begin to research questions stating the
goal using a verb so common verbs are to
characterize to describe to understand
the second sort of principle in writing
a research question is to identify the
topic of interest so we begin with our
verb we're going to characterize
understand describe and then the topic
of interest what is it specifically that
this research study will address
important to use neutral or non
directional language this gets back to
the principle of being exploratory again
we don't have assumptions so we're not
looking for instance only two
facilitators of adoption of a new
practice in a
little setting but rather non
directionally exploring the process of
implementation itself both positive and
negative dimensions a research question
must define the sample and the setting
again with as much precision as possible
the precision is really critical in a
qualitative research question again
because it it gives boundaries to to the
question so let's review together some
sample qualitative research questions
this first question was from a study
done by a clinical scholar and the
Robert Wood Johnson program Kelly Duran
who is interested in the care of
patients in the emergency department
this is the research question for her
study she sought to understand
interpersonal and system level factors
relevant to delivering health care to
emergency department patients who are
homeless so if we look back at those
guiding principles we begin with a verb
we're going to understand this
phenomenon we name the topic with with
boundaries around the edges of what
we're interested in looking at he or she
was very clear to say she was interested
in both interpersonal and system level
factors that might be relevant to
delivering care in the Eady and again
what is the patient setting the patient
population and the setting she's
interested in patients who are homeless
and so this very clearly outlines the
objective of her particular research
study let's look at another example here
a study by Emily teacher Ellen and her
team here at the Yale Global Health
leadership institute this is a study
interested in hospital performance and
care of patients with heart attacks and
the research question for this project
was to identify hospital discharge
processes that may be associated with
better performance in hospital
ami care as measured by mortality rates
so here again we have the verb she's
going to identify these processes the
topic itself and the setting and lastly
this study our team undertook here at
the global
Leadership Institute to describe the
experiences of people who are in
leadership roles in sub-saharan Africa
and this research question is to
characterize the experiences of
individuals in key health care
leadership roles in sub-saharan Africa
so again to name the topic the
population and the setting very clearly
in the research question so let's take a
couple of minutes together to critique a
research question this is a question
brought to me by a student he wasn't
interested in contraception use broadly
and he came with this research question
the purpose of this study is to
understand the knowledge attitudes
beliefs preferences and barriers
regarding contraception use among women
so if we parse this a little bit against
the criteria that we reviewed earlier we
want to be careful that the the study as
its defined in the research question is
feasible and that there are boundaries
that are manageable and that the
specific phenomenon we're interested in
is very clear so here if we look at the
topic as being knowledge attitudes
beliefs preferences of barriers it's
really quite a waterfront to cover
frankly impossible maybe in our
lifetimes and also we want to be precise
about the setting and the population
women is just you know rather broad so
we work together to craft a question
that would meet those criteria that we
reviewed together earlier and the final
question looked like this the study was
to characterize barriers to
contraception use so very specifically
focused on the barriers themselves among
young latina women at high risk for
unintended pregnancy this this question
addressed a very specific gap in the
literature was clearly much more
feasible to implement and very precise
in the nature of what was going to be
looked at in terms of the data
collection and analysis focusing
so a few concluding comments a
well-developed research question is
essential for the success of a study for
the reasons that we've described so it's
not as simple as it seems and yet it's
critically important to the success of a
study so spend time developing and
honing your research question invest
time in defining the knowledge gap
really so important to be sure that we
are in fact contributing to the
advancement of science and so really
critical to master the literature to
know what is known and what is not known
about your focal topic ensure the
question is feasible if we think back to
the study on contraception
you know unpacking all of those
dimensions of contraception use among
women would not have been feasible use
the research question to guide the
choice of method and set the boundaries
for analysis
finally this applies to really all the
research that we do be sure it passes
the sowhat test so thank you for your
attention